where are we going to take this well
looking again how far do i have to
scroll here we go
looking at the question it says part i
can you taste it use part e to deduce
that this inequality is true so again
we've got another set of these linked
inequalities and i'm going to have to
use this to complete this tied up a nice
neat bow at the end right what i'm going
to do is i'm going to start back at part
a that was so many parts ago i can't
remember what it was about and they told
me to use it explicitly anyway so i'm
going to say hey from e
what was true again well let's let's go
back okay
part e was all the way back how many
pages do i have to scroll there's f here
we go here's e okay so what i got was
this result here so i'll take that
without accidentally making it bigger
take that result right there let's grab
it
and i'm going to use this as my
foundation for my question here it is
question i
okay there we go
that'll do me okay so that's what i got
from part e
but i can actually say if you look at
this carefully right this result here
i can make a statement about relating
this to pi squared on six because have a
look at this right um here is the the
sigma notation right in here oh i've
already used that column let's see this
notation here it's right here
and what we're trying to say is hey
that's less than pi squared on 6. well
we have this here it's equal to pi
squared on 6 take away something now
thankfully back from like primary school
we learned that subtraction makes things
smaller but then in like year 7 we muck
that all up by introducing negative
numbers right if you subtract a negative
number you get bigger not smaller okay
however i want you to think all the way
back it's actually in the first part of
the question might even be before the
first part it's like in the introduction
what do we know that tells us that that
won't happen you're not subtracting a
negative here the answer is this result
here b n on a n it's actually provided
to you in the question even if you don't
reason it from the graph that both b n
and a n are positive right so therefore
if these are positive double it still
positive you're subtracting something
positive so therefore you're going to
have something smaller we need to reason
that through so i'm going to say but
since both of those things are positive
a n is greater than 0 and b n
is greater than 0. what that tells me is
that the quotient b n on a n that itself
is going to be zero divide two positive
numbers you'll get another positive
number out which means that minus two if
you multiply that through then it's
going to switch that inequality around
that's got to be negative right and so
you can say oh look i just need to get
to this right so i'm going to add pi
squared on 6 to both sides pi squared on
6 take away
this
is less than i added pi squared on 6 to
the left so i'll add it to the right but
this thing here on the left hand side
that is my sigma notation from part e
right so i can say i'm just going to
grab the whole thing i can say this
thing therefore now switches into
my inequality it's less than pi squared
on 6. okay so what i've got now is this
result here i'm like sweet this part of
the inequality is settled now i just
have to look over here on the left okay
pause for a moment you need to think
carefully about this because not quite
so obvious we've used party they told us
to use party but then like how do i get
to what's happening over here on the
left hand side right have a look
carefully at what they're asking you to
prove look at this and see if anything
looks familiar okay
when you see on that left hand side that
pi cubed on eight uh n plus one right
that should signal to you that there's
something suspicious right when was the
last time we saw that and the answer is
that pi cubed appeared in our previous
question didn't it scroll all the way
there right um here's the pi cubed right
i've got
b n over here um all the way on the left
hand side um and on the right hand side
i've got this pi cubed appearing right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
grab this
this result right here that whole thing
copy that bring it down
i'm going to say where am i getting this
from answer from part h so i'll invoke
that i'll say from h
i know that this whole messy inequality
this long inequality is true right well
if this is bigger than this is bigger
than this clearly if you look at the
thing that's biggest it will be bigger
than the thing that is smallest here
right so i can actually cut out that
middle man this is unimportant to me
right i really just want this pie cubed
on i want the h in there n plus one okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say since that is true
eliminating the middle expression
that just leaves me with
eliminating
an expression are both very long words
to write
[Applause]
in fact i'm going to be excessively lazy
i'm going to grab that and i'm going to
very literally eliminate that middle
expression like so
there we go so it leaves us with this
okay and that doesn't need to be blue
anymore i think we know where it comes
from okay
all right so i've got this result okay
now how do i relate this to what i've
got above look carefully okay we've got
um we don't have ans bns right we've got
this sigma notation think back to where
you used sigma notation and combine that
with a n and b n um don't you remember
let's go all the way back how far do i
need to go
a n b n it's all the way back oh here we
go
okay you can see here um i've got this
relationship here about this a and b in
business okay and so i can say oh hold
on a second i can actually just divide
through right i can say let's come back
over here so i'm using the same result
twice okay
did i oh no go further there we go
i'm going to divide through by a n and
i'm going to multiply by uh two at the
same time okay so you can see i'm going
to end up with this a n term ending up
on the left hand side so it's going to
come b and on a n and while i'm at it
i'm going to multiply by 2 because that
will give me
this result that you can see right here
okay
so
2 b n on a n on the right hand side or
left hand side i should say and then the
pi cubed on 8
and plus 1 on the right hand side does
that look suspicious right this is
exactly the result that i needed on the
left hand most part of my set of
inequalities okay
so from here
let's see i've actually got
have a look there pi squared on 6 take
away this result right pi squared on 6
take away this so a couple of things can
happen at the same time number one let's
multiply both sides by
minus one
and when i do that
pi cubed on eight of n plus one when you
do that that of course switches the
direction of the inequality and while
i'm also doing that let me add pi
squared on 6 here
and
here so you can see look at that
this is the result that i really needed
on the left hand side of my inequality
it's right there okay see that
okay can you taste it so close maybe
you've already um you know you've beat
me to it right the weird thing is it's
on the right here i actually need it on
the left so let's grab this chuck it
over here
and then take this one here
and pop it on the right and since
they're switched sides my inequality
switches back to being a less than or
equal to
okay
going back to my result from e they
asked me to use this right do you
remember this here's my part e result
that i used right here that pi squared
on 6 minus 2 bn on a n that's
right here right so i can substitute
that for the sigma notation that i saw
before so i'm going to say that i'm
going to substitute
a
[Applause]
into the right hand side
like so all right so
everything here is just going to stay
put
but then on the right hand side is this
c notation right so i'm going to write
that as
sigma from i think it's k equals 1 to n
of 1 on k squared if i'm not mistaken
okay so finally just going back
you can see i can combine that with i
think i was a bit cheeky and i didn't
write i didn't label it let's call this
one
um inequality three i can link that it's
so many lines before you really have to
if you want to communicate clearly
you've got to stay it right i'm going to
link
with
[Applause]
3
which is going to give me this is going
to be on the left hand side
okay i'm a bit sick of that highlighting
now let's get rid of it and then if you
have a look
this is the less than or equal to pi on
6 that's just going to appear on that
right hand side
okay that's it that's as required so i
might as well conclude and can you
believe it we are now at part j this is
the final part we're going to take this
result even though they haven't said
hence or otherwise like what else are
you going to use today don't need to
zoom in on that what else you're going
to use to prove this okay in order to
prove this result i need i do need a bit
more space i think if i just like say
question mark it's going to give me a
new page yes okay
what am i going to do here right well
i'm just going to follow from the tail
of my previous line right so here
is this inequality which i've got from
part i so i'll just copy that
and i'll say from i
here comes the inequality right now look
carefully at this result
when you've got
this result here you can see this is
important because it appears in what
we're asked being asked to evaluate here
right um what is the limit right the
difference is there are no limits in
part i i need to add the limits into
this question and then see what happens
okay now of course you can't just add
limits to this you know this set of this
expression in the middle and not add it
to the ones on the outside but just
before you do you've got to be a little
bit cautious right
when you add in these limits the limit
as n approaches infinity infinity is a
bit of a slippery character you know
you've got to be careful with it so when
you deal with it over here i'll put some
big brackets around this because the
limits being applied to everything
everything is fine okay so you've got
that now we've got the limit as n
approaches infinity of this result here
sigma
k equals 1
1 on k squared but here comes the clinch
up right
when you have a look at this part here
it is this is going to be strictly less
than pi squared on six right and the
reason for that is because you've got
kind of it's a bit like with geometric
series this is not a geometric series
but behaves a lot like a geometric
series and then it's got this idea of a
limiting sum yeah it's like i'm
approaching you know
a quarter sorry a half plus a quarter
plus an eighth plus a sixteenth it's
getting closer and closer to one but as
long as you have a finite number of
terms you'll never get there right
however
we no longer have a finite number of
terms like i wrote here we're saying
what if we went to infinity so in fact
that less than pi squared on 6 is now
going to become less than or equal to
because we don't actually know if pi
squared on 6 if if i can reach there or
not right and there's going to be
reasons why you're going to see actually
you're gonna need to to think about this
right
okay so remember what we're trying to
evaluate it's this part in here this
limit so i don't need to touch that
right but on the left hand side you can
actually do something with this limit
that's not too complicated to see if you
just turn your eyes to this term here
it's the only term in the left hand side
which has an n in it so the pi squared
on 6 is independent of n so i'm just
going to write that like so
and then we'll think about what happens
to pi cubed on 8 n plus 1 as n gets very
very large
the n is in the denominator so therefore
as n gets huge the denominator gets used
the whole thing is going to vanish away
to 0. so i'm going to say take away 0
and now i've evaluated that entire limit
then oh that's a bit cheeky i should
have said that the limits applied to
this as well it doesn't matter of course
because it's independent of n but i
still need to say it i've now got
everything here nothing's been changed
there and then on the right hand side
i've got pi squared on 6.
what
pi squared on 6 is less than or equal to
this which is less than or equal to pi
squared on 6. now it's true pi squared
on 6 is less than or equal to pi squared
on 6 because it's equal to the boundary
condition is there but then somehow
you've got this
weirdo expression jammed in the middle
and this is what we call you'll see a
couple of different names for it
depending on where you learn it from
sometimes it's called the squeeze law
that's what i was taught when i went to
university and it's pretty standard in a
first-year university mathematics course
or another name that i've encountered
which i think is quite adorable is the
sandwich theorem because i picture this
term here in the middle of the
inequality being the meat in the
sandwich between these other two things
these two pieces of bread which happen
to be identical they're both pi squared
on six and you're squeezing nothing in
between them so that thing has to be pie
squared on six as well right so
therefore i can say
i can conclude
let's write this this is the final line
of my proof
that therefore the uh oops this is an
equals the limit oh i didn't write the
limit right the same notation first i
got it carried away the limit
as n approaches infinity
of k equals 1
all the way up to infinity of the sum of
the reciprocals of the squares that is
equal to
pi squared on
six
what on earth this is such a bizarre
result and you can see why the basil
problem remained unsold for decades um
and it took a i bet it would have
remained unsolved for even longer if a
mind as masterful as oilers had not come
along to solve it
so
thank you so much for sticking with me
if you got all the way to the end there
this is a mountain of a problem and i
really enjoyed going all the way through
it and i love that the knowledge we have
in mathematics extension too like look
through it's a lot of integration by
parts and some careful use of algebras
and inequalities and we were able to get
there and solve this truly historic
problem that that really eluded some of
the best mathematicians in the world
throughout history so
hope you enjoyed that
[Applause]